all right let me tell you about building
synthetic cells and printing life
but first let me tell you a quick story
on March 31st 2013 my team and I
received an email from an international
health organization alerting us that two
men died in China
shortly after contracting age seven and
nine bird flu there are fears of a
global pandemic as the virus started
rapidly moving across China although
methods existed to produce a flu vaccine
and stop the disease from spreading at
best it would not be available for at
least six months this is because a slow
antiquated flu vaccine manufacturing
process developed over 70 years ago was
the only option the virus would need to
be isolated from infected patients
packaged up and then sent to a facility
where scientists would inject the virus
into chicken eggs and incubate those
chicken eggs for several weeks in order
to prepare the virus for the start of a
multi-step multi month flu vaccine
manufacturing process my team and I
received this email because we had just
invented a biological printer which
would allow for the flu vaccine
instructions to be instantly downloaded
from the internet and printed
drastically speeding up the way in which
flu vaccines are made and potentially
saving thousands of lives the biological
printer leverages our ability to read
and write DNA and starts to bring into
focus what we like to call biological
teleportation I am a biologist and an
engineer who builds stuff out of DNA
believe it or not one of my favorite
things to do is to take DNA apart and
put it back together so that I can
understand better how it works I can
edit and program DNA to do things just
like coders programming a computer but
my apps are different they create life
self-replicating living cells and things
like vaccines and therapeutics that work
in ways that were previously impossible
here is National Medal of Science
recipient
craig Venter and Nobel laureate ham
Smith these two guys shared a similar
vision that vision was because all of
the functions and characteristics of all
biological entities including viruses
and living cells are written into the
code of DNA if one can read and write
that code of DNA then they can be
reconstructed in a distant location this
is what we mean by biological
teleportation to prove out this vision
Craig and ham set a goal of creating for
the first time a synthetic cell starting
from DNA code in the computer I mean
come on as a scientist looking for a job
doing cutting-edge research it doesn't
get any better than this okay a genome
is a complete set of DNA within an
organism following the human genome
project in 2003 which was an
international effort to identify the
complete genetic blueprint of a human
being a genomics revolution happened
scientists started mastering the
techniques for reading DNA in order to
determine the order of the AEC's T's and
G's within an organism but my job was
far different
I needed to master the techniques for
writing DNA like an author of a book
this started out as writing short
sentences or sequences of DNA code but
this soon turned into writing paragraphs
and then full-on novels of DNA code to
make important biological instructions
for proteins and living cells living
cells are nature's most efficient
machines at making new products
accounting for the production of 25% of
the total pharmaceutical market which is
billions of dollars we knew that writing
DNA would drive this bio economy even
more once cells could be programmed just
like computers we also knew that writing
DNA would enable biological
teleportation the printing of defined
biological material starting from DNA
code as a step toward bringing these
promises to fruition our team set out to
create for the first time a synthetic
bacterial cell starting from DNA code in
the computer synthetic DNA is
commodity you can order very short
pieces of DNA from a number of companies
and they will start from these four
bottles of chemicals that make up DNA ga
t and C and they will build those very
short pieces of DNA for you over the
past 15 years or so my teams have been
developing the technology for stitching
together those short pieces of DNA into
complete bacterial genomes the largest
genome that we constructed contained
over 1 million letters which is more
than twice the size of your average
novel we had to put every single one of
those letters in the correct order
without a single typo we were able to
accomplish this by developing a
procedure that I tried to call the
one-step isothermal in-vitro
recombination method but surprisingly
the science community didn't like this
technically accurate name and decided to
call it Gibson assembly Gibson assembly
is now the gold standard tool used in
laboratories around the world for
building short and long pieces of DNA
once we chemically synthesized a
complete bacterial genome our next
challenge was to find a way to convert
it into a free-living self-replicating
cell our approach was to think of the
genome as the operating system of the
cell with the cell containing the
hardware necessary to boot up the genome
through a lot of trial and error we
developed a procedure where we could
reprogram cells and even convert one
bacterial species into another by
replacing the genome of one cell with
that of another this genome
transplantation technology then paved
the way for the booting up of genomes
written by scientists and not by mother
nature in 2010 all of the technologies
that we had been developing for reading
and writing DNA all came together when
we announced the creation of the first
synthetic cell which of course we called
Cynthia ever since the first bacterial
genome was sequenced back in 1995
thousands more whole bacterial genomes
have been sequenced and stored in
computer databases our synthetic cell
work was the proof of concept that we
could reverse this process pull a
complete bacterial genome sequence out
of the computer and convert that
information into a free-living
self-replicating cell with all of the
expected characteristics of the species
that we constructed now I can understand
why there may be concerns about the
safety of this level of genetic
manipulation while the technology has
the potential for great societal benefit
it also has a potential for doing harm
with this in mind even before carrying
out the very first experiment our team
started to work with the public in the
government to find solutions to together
to responsibly develop and regulate this
new technology one of the outcomes from
those discussions was to screen every
customer and every customers DNA
synthesis orders to make sure that
pathogens or toxins are not being made
by bad guys or accidentally by
scientists all suspicious orders are
reported to the FBI another relevant
lawn for
spin agencies synthetic cell
technologies will power the next
Industrial Revolution and transform
industries and economies in ways that
address global sustainability challenges
the possibilities are endless
I mean you can think of clothes
constructed from renewable bio-based
sources cars running on biofuel from
engineered microbes plastics made from
biodegradable polymers and customized
therapies printed at a patient's bedside
the massive efforts to create synthetic
cells have made us world leaders at
writing DNA throughout the process we
found ways to write DNA faster more
accurately and more reliably because of
the robustness of these technologies we
found that we could readily automate the
processes and move the laboratory
workflows out of the scientists hands
and onto a machine in 2013 we built the
first DNA printer we call it the bio XP
and it has been absolutely essential in
writing DNA across a number of
applications my team and researchers
around the world are working on it was
shortly after we built the bio XP that
we received that email about the h7n9
bird flu scare in China a team of
Chinese scientists had already isolated
the virus sequenced its DNA and uploaded
the DNA sequence to the Internet at the
request of the US government we
downloaded the DNA sequence and in less
than 12 hours we printed it on the bio
XP our collaborators at Novartis then
quickly started turning that synthetic
DNA into a flu vaccine meanwhile the CDC
using technology dating back to the
1940s was still waiting for the virus to
arrive from China so that they could
begin their AG based approach for the
first time we had a flu vaccine
developed ahead of time for a new and
potentially dangerous strain and the US
government ordered a stockpile
this was when I began to appreciate more
than ever the power of biological
teleportation naturally with this in
mind we started to build a biological
teleporter we call it the DBC that's
short for a digital to biological
converter
unlike the bio XP which starts from
pre-manufactured short pieces of DNA the
DVC starts from digitized DNA code and
converts that DNA code into biological
entities such as DNA RNA proteins or
even viruses you can think of the bio XP
as a DVD player requiring a physical DVD
to be inserted whereas the DVC
is netflix to build the DVC
my team of scientists worked with
software and instrumentation engineers
to collapse multiple laboratory
workflows all in a single box this
included software algorithms to predict
what DNA to build chemistry to link the
GA t and C building blocks of DNA into
short pieces skips an assembly to stitch
together those short pieces and the much
longer ones and biology to convert the
DNA into other biological entities such
as proteins this is the prototype
although it wasn't pretty it was
effective and made therapeutic drugs and
vaccines and laboratory workflows that
once took weeks or months could now be
carried out in just one to two days and
that's all without any human
intervention and simply activated by the
receipt of an email which could be sent
from anywhere in the world we like to
compare the DBC to fax machines but
whereas fax machines receive images and
documents the DBC receives biological
materials now consider how fax machines
have evolved the prototype of the 1840s
is unrecognizable compared with the fax
machines of today in the 1980s most
people still didn't know what a fax
machine was and if they did it was
difficult for them to grasp the concept
of instantly reproducing an image on the
other side of the world but nowadays
everything that effects
Sheen does is integrated on our
smartphones and of course we take this
rapid exchange of digital information
for granted here's what our DBC looks
like today we imagine the DBC evolving
in similar ways as fax machines have
we're working to reduce the size of the
instrument and we're working to make the
underlying technology more reliable
cheaper faster and more accurate
accuracy is extremely important when
synthesizing DNA because a single change
to a DNA letter could mean the
difference between a medicine working or
not or synthetic cell being alive or
dead the DBC will be useful for the
distributed manufacturing of Medicine
starting from DNA every hospital in the
world could use a DBC for printing
personalized medicines for a patient at
their bedside I can even imagine a day
when it's routine for people to have a
DBC to connect to their home computer or
smartphone as a means to download their
prescriptions such as insulin or
antibody therapies the DVC will also be
valuable when placed in strategic areas
around the world for a rapid response to
disease outbreaks for example the CDC in
Atlanta Georgia could send flu vaccine
instructions to a DBC on the other side
of the world where the flu vaccine is
manufactured right on the frontlines
that flu vaccine could even be
specifically tailored to the flu strain
that's in that circuit that's
circulating in that local area setting
vaccines around in a digital file rather
than stockpiling those same vaccines and
shipping them out promises to save
thousands of lives
of course the applications go as far as
the imagination goes it's not hard to
imagine placing a DBC on another planet
scientists on earth could then send the
digital instructions to that DBC to make
new medicines or to make synthetic
organisms that produce oxygen food fuel
or building materials as a means for
making the planet more habitable for
humans
with digital information traveling at
the speed of light it would only take
minutes to send those digital
instructions from Earth to Mars but it
would take months to physically deliver
those same samples on a spacecraft but
for now I would be satisfied beaming new
medicines across the globe fully
automated and on-demand saving lives
from emerging infectious diseases and
printing personalized cancer medicines
for those who don't have time to wait
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]